[Musique]
robert boulin s'est il suicidé ou a t'il
en fait été assassiné plus de quatre ans
après les faits un second rapport
d'autopsié du corps de l'ancien ministre
du travail de valéry giscard d'estaing
paraît contredire l'hypothèse du suicide
en tout cas aux yeux de sa famille est
le fils de robert boulin n'hésitent pas
aujourd'hui à lier la disparition de son
père à la sphère des avions renifleurs
d'elf aquitaine
marcel trillât et jean marc dubois c'est
ici en forêt de rambouillet que l'on
avait retrouvé le corps de robert boulin
le 9 octobre 1979 à 9 heures du matin
sur le bord de l'étang de hollande la
mort remontait à la veille au soir dans
sa voiture un bristol portant quelques
mots d'adieu à sa famille très vite les
enquêteurs concluent au suicide par
noyade
d'autant plus que robert boulin qui
était l'objet d'une campagne de presse
avait écrit la veille plusieurs lettres
dans lesquelles il annoncé son intention
d'en finir mais le 7 juin 1983 bertrand
belin le fils de l'ancien ministre sa
soeur et sa mère dépose une plainte
contre x pour homicide volontaire le 29
octobre dernier le corps est exhumé et
une nouvelle autopsie est pratiquée
les experts relèvent d'abord l'absence
dans le rapport de la première autopsie
de toute analyse des poumons qui aurait
pourtant permis de conclure si robert
boulin était mort par noyade ou non les
contrôles radiologiques leur permettent
surtout de constater deux fractures
l'une des os du nez
l'autre de la mâchoire or au moment du
décès le procureur de la république
avait interdit l'examen du crâne les
constatations qui rendent de plus en
plus fragile la thèse du suicide v6 ne
s'agit pas d'un celui-ci c'est
évidemment un assassinat pour l'instant
nous sommes sur ce sont les médecins
emploie le mot de coûts directs et
violent il dit à envisage également
l'hypothèse d'une fuite sur un objet
contendant mais je connais bien les
lieux il n'y a pas de sol dur d'objets
contendants donc il a été battu battu
n'avons pas la preuve de la festina
mais cette thèse là et quand même en
train de se vérifier vos bons barbeau
s'il y a
assassinat quel serait alors le mobile
alors vous savez ça c'est en effet
compliqué ce que je peux vous dire d'une
manière très claire c'est que mon père
s'était aperçu comme
il avait décrit je ne parle pas de la
posthume mais comme il l'avait écrit
déjà que ses propres amis politiques
l'avait trahi un homme qui se sent trahi
qui se sent attaqué peut se défendre et
bien entendu à ce moment là donnez des
dossiers si ces dossiers étaient trop
importants eh bien on peut comprendre
qu'on les tue et je ne dis pas que c'est
ça je dis que c'est une thèse et une
thèse qui se vérifie chaque jour alors
c'est haussier ce sont des dossiers qui
concernaient toute une série d'affaires
financières je vous dis ça j'ai l'air
très sûr de moi mais je le suis parce
que ce sont des dossiers que j'avais vu
dans son coffre alors que ça concernait
quoi et qui ça c'est compliqué parce que
quand vous voyez quelque chose d'écrit
j'ai vu sécurité sociale un jour une
autre fois j'ai vu elle fait rap
une autre fois j'ai vu une entreprise
qui est aujourd'hui nationalisées mais
qui n'était pas à l'époque
eh bien à chaque fois on a vu ça
effectivement mais sont des dossiers
kaminis des finances puisque avant
d'être au travail était mise des
finances a normalement c'est nous qui en
déduisant que c'était ça la sphère
boulin une affaire judiciaire qui
pourrait bien dans les jours qui
viennent connaître des prolongements sur
le terrain politique
[Musique]